gestern haben wir hier bei bild live
über den zerstückelter berichtet hells
angels bosse rahmen yekta parras wird
von der polizei gejagt mit
internationalem haftbefehl
denn für die ermittler ist klar der mann
ließ einen angeblichen verräter eiskalt
erschossen seine leiche zersägen und im
rhein versenkt danach floh der hells
angels bosna und unseren kollegen von
achtung fahndungen ist es am abend
gelungen den genauen aufenthaltsort des
zerstörers herauszufinden unsere
spezialisten haben ihn im norden
teherans aufgespürt und offenbar
verfolgt der mutmaßliche killer in iran
achtung fahndung und bild.de denn vor
wenigen minuten hatte sich auf instagram
selbst geäußert und wir schauen uns das
mal an
zu den ganzen vorwürfen
die mir vorgeworfen worden sind von der
presse
diese ganze
flucht aktionen die ich angeblich
begangen habe
zum nächsten kleines statement gehen
da werde ich auch dementsprechend
auch wirklich zu sagen
aufenthaltsort was ja so spannend
geheimnis
dem entsprechen was zu sagen das wird
du bist so viele hinweise
braucht
das medienspektakel zu machen
oder irgendwelche
dann darfst du zu starten oder
irgendwelche
wer betrunken zu wollen
geführt werden
natürlich haben wir bei der polizei in
duisburg nachgefragt was sie von dem
video hält die ermittler gegen beachtung
fanden wir sind gespannt auf weitere
statements des flüchtlingen er kann aber
auch gerne bei uns vorbeikommen und
persönlich aussagen
[Musik]